- [Instructor] So what I
have here is an expression
where I'm multiplying
rational expressions.
And we want to do this multiplication
and then reduce to lowest terms.
So if you feel so inspired,
I encourage you to pause
this video and see if you
can have a go at that.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So multiplying rational
expressions like this,
it's very analogous to
multiplying fractions.
For example, if I were to multiply 6/25
times 15/9, there's a
few ways you could do it.
You could just multiply six
times 15 in the numerator,
and 25 times nine in the denominator.
But the way that many of us approach it
so that it's easier to
reduce to lowest terms
is to factor things, to realize that look,
six is two times three.
Nine is three times three,
15 is three times five,
and 25 is five times five.
And then you can realize
in your eventual product
you're going to have a five
in the numerator, five in the denominator.
You can, five divided by five is one,
three divided by three is one,
and then three divided by three is one.
And so all you'd be left with is that two
and then that five.
So this is going to be equal to 2/5.
So we'll do the analogous thing
here with these rational expressions.
We're going to factor them,
all of them in the
numerators and denominators.
And then we'll see if we
can divide the numerator
and the denominator by the same thing.
Now, the one thing we have to make sure
of as we do that is we
keep track of the domain.
'Cause these rational expressions here,
they might have x values
that make their
denominators equal to zero.
And so even if we reduce to lowest terms,
and we get rid of those expressions,
in order for the expressions
to be the same expression,
we have to constrain the
domain in the same way.
So let's get started.
So this is going to be equal to,
I'll just rewrite everything,
x squared minus nine.
How do we factor that?
Well, that's going to be
a difference of squares.
We could write that as x plus
three times x minus three.
And then that is going
to be over this business.
And let's see, five squared is 25,
negative five plus negative
five is negative 10.
So this is going to be x minus five
times x minus five.
If what I'm just doing
here with the factoring
is not making sense,
I encourage you to review
factoring on Khan Academy.
And then we multiply
that times, let's see,
in this numerator here,
I can factor out of four.
So that's going to be
four times x minus five.
Which is going to be useful.
I have an x minus five
there, x minus five there.
And then that's going to be over.
Let's see, this expression over here.
Two plus three is five,
two times three to six.
So it's going to be x plus
two times x plus three.
Now before I start
reducing to lowest terms,
let's think about the domain here.
And the domain is going to be constrained
by things that make these
denominators equal to zero.
So the domain would be all real numbers
except x cannot equal five.
Let me write it over here.
X cannot equal five
because if that happened,
then this denominator would become zero.
X cannot be equal to negative two.
X could not be equal to negative two
because that would make
the denominator here zero,
which would make the
denominator here zero.
And x cannot be equal to negative three.
So the domain is constrained in this way.
We have to carry this throughout.
No matter what we do to the expression,
this is the constraints on our domain.
With that out of the way, now
we can reduce to lowest terms.
So x, we have an x plus
three in the numerator,
x plus three in the denominator.
X minus five in the numerator.
X minus five in the denominator.
And I think we've gone
about as far as we can.
And so when we multiply the numerators,
we are going to get,
this business is going to
be four times x minus three.
Four times x minus three,
over, we have an x minus five here.
X minus five.
And then we have an x plus two.
We have an x plus two.
And we could leave it
like this if you want.
In some cases,
people like to multiply the
things out, but we're done.
We've just finished multiplying
these rational expressions.
And we have to remind ourselves
that x cannot be equal
to any of these things.
Now, the way that we've simplified it,
we still have an x minus
five right over here.
So it might be redundant
to say that x cannot
be equal to five because
that's still the case
in our reduced terms expression here.
And that's true also of
the x cannot be equal
to negative two.
We still have an x plus two here.
So still, even in this
expression it's pretty clear,
that x cannot be equal to negative two,
but the x cannot equal negative three
isn't so obvious when you
just look at this expression.
But in order for this expression
to be completely
equivalent to the original,
it has to have the same domain.
And so you might want to explicitly say
that x cannot be equal
to negative three here.
You could also say the other two,
but those are, that's still very clear
when you look at this expression.